قال رئيس تركيا رجب طيب اردوغان ان
الاجتماع الثنائي الذي جرى مع الرئيس
المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي بواسطه امير
دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال ثاني في
الدوحه كان بهدف ازاله قطيعه استمرت تسع
سنين تصريحات الرئيس التركي جاءت خلال
لقائه مع تشكيله حزبه في مدينه كوريا
لازاله قطيعه استمر تسع سنين واستمعت في
ذلك المساء ثنائيا مع السيد السيسي لمده
30 الى 45 دقيقه
اتفقنا معه على ان تتم الاجتماعات على
مستوى الوزراء وبعدها نرفع مستوى اللقاءات
ونطورها اخبرته ان تركيا مهتمه بازاله
القطيعه والخلاف مع مصر وعدم حصول مشكله
بيننا في البحر الابيض المتوسط كما ناقشنا
كثيرا من المواضيع في اللقاء الثنائي
بيننا في قطر فيما بعد قليل ان السيد
السيسي كان سعيدا جدا بالاجتماع